allez un chiffre 82 qu'est-ce que c'est
à votre avis
Sophie ce sont des centimètres
au début j'étais content d'apprendre que
Al Pacino était vivant parce que je ne
savais même pas
mais non il est venu à Paris qu'il
allait devenir papa c'est à dire que
quand son fils enlèvera les petites
routes son vélo je ne sais pas si il
sera encore ce monde je trouve ça
légèrement angoissant maintenant
et surtout tout ce qui est très étrange
c'est capacino dans plusieurs interviews
dit qu'il a beaucoup souffert de
l'absence de son papa et qu'il aimerait
pas reproduire ça avec ses enfants donc
je trouve ça un peu alors je te confirme
qu'il est vivant parce qu'il était il y
a 15 jours à Paris où il a donné une
masterclass à la Salle Pleyel voilà mais
en ce qui concerne en tout cas un Patino
sa fiancée comme tu l'as dit à 29 ans
effectivement est enceinte de 8 mois
selon les infos du site people TMZ qui
sont toujours très très bien informés et
importe parole de l'acteur à confirmer
l'information au site Al Pacino est déjà
père de Julie 33 ans issu de sa relation
avec Yann Tarente ainsi que deux jumeaux
l'hiver et Anton 22 ans déjà qu'il a eu
avec Beverly Hills d'Angelo qui était
magnifique il est plus âgé que le père
de sa femme quand même mais oui mais je
fais comment
ça commence à être un peu la limite
quand même
ça ne vous échappera pas que c'est
messieurs dans certains
nage grande
star comme De Niro Al Pacino de pour moi
les deux acteurs que je préfère au monde
mais bon laissons ça de côté ça ne vous
échappera pas que pour garder ces jeunes
filles elles veulent quand même avoir un
petit bébé peut-être qu'elle lui a pas
demandé son avis voilà donc ensuite
il est plus fort possible il a rien dit
et puis peut-être tu sais gaz surpris on
se dit tiens ça marche encore
il y a de fortes chances pour qu'il ait
congelé ça semence à cet âge-là en
général c'est ce qu'ils font ça
et parce que je sais je sais beaucoup de
choses que vous ne savez pas Bernard
travail dans un congélateur
et non mais c'est probablement ce qui a
dû se passer donc je pense qu'il était
au courant quand même de l'histoire
m'a fait un bébé dans le dos je crois
pas mais c'est pas c'est pas un mec
c'est l'ex de Mick Jagger
mais c'était pas confirmé cette relation
ils étaient ensemble
Nick Jagger et c'est le coup de foudre
le milieu artistique et quand ils sont
ensemble il faut rarement des lectures
publiques
et donc aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose
à toi le week-end et alors s'ils font
pas des lectures publiques j'ai peur de
te demander qu'est-ce qu'ils font
penser
attention on a les deux au milieu
occupez vous d'elle un peu